history contains an essentially infinite
amount of suffering and atrocities and
outrages and injustices it also contains
heroism and sacrifice and courage it is
up to us to decide which of those things
in our National History we will focus on
I contend that the healthiest category
to focus on the thing that you focus on
if you want to be a thriving and happy
and healthy Society is the latter which
isn't to say that we outright deny and
never discuss the former of course we
acknowledge that bad things were done in
our history we shouldn't try erase that
from the history books and nobody is but
ultimately you will look back on your
history with pride and gratitude or with
resentment and despair you will focus on
the Triumph or the tragedy